i'm here with andy cohen who brings out
the best in me and rusty ross matthews
rossie ross i love when andy's here can
we keep him can we keep him i don't know
i love him i want him to leave rossy
oh my god what is going on
[Laughter]
well we're going to play a game called
what in the blank
scientific
andy is the king of pop culture and we
love pop culture for real i love that
ross and i tackle headlines every day on
drew's news together
as co-pilot in the world and we want to
put that knowledge to the test now okay
ross you are the master of ceremonies
i'm so excited a game with andy i know
there's gonna be only one winner i'm
gonna throw up a recent pop culture
headline and you'll take turns filling
in the missing information the blank if
you will whoever gets the most correct
will have confetti popped over them and
bragging rights forever are you ready
confetti is on
the line
i get so serious when it comes to
competition okay ready i'm so excited
all right here we go okay andy first
question is to you okay camilla cabello
debuted a new blank in tribute to mother
nature this week
new nose
i guess that wouldn't be a tribute to
mother nature no a new fragrance
okay he says fragrance the answer is
neck tattoo a neck tattoo i know look
right here it is yeah well it was sort
of tough you know but she's head and
shoulders above everyone else okay a
little neck joke okay
up next drew your turn jennifer lopez
and ben affleck made out on a blank like
the rom-com stars that they are an
airport private jet tarmac yes that is
correct i saw those pictures good job
look at them
that was them after a central park walk
yeah
okay security
okay
andy you got to get on the board here kj
oppa put his wife uh clara berry's blank
in his coffee breast milk breast milk is
the right answer
i love him i love it you know archie
andrews in riverdale cute super cute all
right tie game drew this is your
question blank and blank were just
announced in the wicked film adaptation
as galinda and elphaba
okay
ariana grande
um
ariana grande andy knows um
oh god
okay andy who is it cynthia revo cynthia
okay
still one to one
andy you gotta get this right okay
listen closely blank is literally making
cal pen's dream come true by offering to
officiate his wedding
is it
cardi b
is it cardi b
wow that is some useless information
[Applause]
thank you now listen drew you've got to
get this right to tie it up or andy wins
you got it okay okay final question drew
kim kardashian will not bring blank to
paris hilton's wedding
is this something that's out there that
she has exclaimed is that she's not
bringing or is this like hypothetical
because of course i'm going to say pete
davidson
[Music]
which means
we have a tie so confetti foreign
[Applause]
everybody seriously andy cohen's new
book glitter everyday 365 quotes from
women i love is available right now
thank you thanks for always bringing
the glitter and the confetti
[Music]
you